[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 8 mars voici les
titres c'est la journée internationale
des droits des femmes à cette occasion
un nouvel accueil de jour pour les
femmes victimes de violence a été
inaugurée aujourd'hui à versailles sur
le même sujet ce soir la gendarmerie
s'allie avec l'association france
victime 78 une convention est signée à
molette nous serons sur place à 34 jours
du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle emmanuel macron et et
hier à poissy le président de la
république sortant ya lancé
officiellement sa campagne
un échange de plus d'une heure avec des
habitants invités par la ville retour
sur la soirée et puis nous prendrons des
nouvelles des cadets de la gendarmerie
d'île de france depuis septembre nous
suivons ces jeunes qui ambitionne
d'exercer dans les métiers de la
sécurité ils viennent de terminer leur
deuxième stage au camp militaire de ben
au programme notamment le devoir de
mémoire volet important de la formation
mais avant de développer ces titres le
château de versailles les jardins et le
grand trianon fermé jusqu'à vendredi
inclus c'est également le cas pour le
petit trianon et le parc pour les
journées de jeudi et vendredi
conséquence du sommet de l'europe qui se
tient ce jeudi et vendredi emmanuel
macron réunit les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de l'union européenne au
château en pleine guerre d'ukraine par
ailleurs de nombreuses restrictions de
circulation et de stationnement sont
mises en place
regardez cette carte qui nous est fourni
par la préfecture des yvelines plusieurs
zones autour du château rouge orange et
jaune qui concerne pour cette dernière
zone les avenues de saint-cloud de
l'europe ainsi qu'une partie du
boulevard de la reine le stationnement
le stationnement des véhicules sera
interdit dans la nuit de mercredi à
jeudi minuit et jusqu'à vendredi 20h en
zone rouge l'accès piéton et la
circulation des véhicules seront
interdits circulation des véhicules est
également prohibé en zone orange qui
elle sera accessible aux piétons
uniquement sur motif valable accès aux
commerces écoles cabinets médicaux sur
présentation d'un justificatif
enfin en zone jaune la circulation sera
ponctuellement interrompue jeudi de
jeudi à vendredi et des mesures qu'on
élémentaire 1 qui viennent aussi
s'ajouter à toutes ces restrictions
notamment la fermeture de la gare
versailles rive gauche de jeudi 10h à
vendredi et 18h pour s'informer une
cellule dédiée est ouverte par le préfet
des yvelines elle est joignable par mail
dès maintenant ou par téléphone en
continu de jeudi 10h à vendredi 20h
[Musique]
mais je vous le disais dans les titres
c'est aujourd'hui la journée
internationale des droits des femmes et
à cette occasion une convention a été
signée il ya quelques minutes entre la
gendarmerie nationale et l'association
france victime 78 et pour l'ouverture
d'une première permanence d aide aux
victimes en brigade de gendarmerie à
houdan la signature a eu lieu justement
à la brigade de gendarmerie de houdan
molette où on retrouve sur place tout de
suite le colonel sylvain tortelier
bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes le
commandant du groupement de gendarmerie
des yvelines je le disais une convention
qui a été signée il ya quelques minutes
quel est l'objectif quels sont les
objectifs de ce partenariat avec
l'association france victime soit 118
pourquoi cette signature se soit
très heureux donc d'avoir paraphé cette
convention entre donc là toutes les
tares j'ai un adjoint de la préfecture
le président de l'association france-98
et donc où l'avait mentionné donc la
gendarmerie des yvelines
et une convention un peu pionnière ici
qui vise en fait à ouvrir les portes de
la brigade de gendarmerie à cette
association qui de manière régulière
tiendra des permanences à caractère
juridique pour le coup afin
d'accompagner les personnes qui
franchissent le pas de la brigade pour
venir déposer plainte sur un probant de
sujets à caractère sexuel chine bref
tous sujets ayant un rapport avec des
faits de dix à part familiale et sa part
de quoi est-ce que ça part d'un constat
on sait que pendant le conflit non ces
faits de violence à l'intérieur des
foyers a augmenté ce que c'est ce que
vous avez constaté aussi en zone rurale
dans les yvelines c'est aussi de ça qui
est parti cette réflexion que cette
union finalement oui à la réflexion
qu'elle est partie évidemment d'un
constat qui fait que depuis quelques
années maintenant on révèle un peu mieux
donc les faits de violences
intrafamiliales et que donc il fallait
que les corps de sécurité singulièrement
la gendarmerie a vers les gens pour lui
révéler ces situations là donc ça a pris
la forme ici notamment dans les bilans
que d'un agent troc c'est à dire d'un
poste mobile avancée qui vient dans la
profondeur des territoires au contact
des gens pour leur signaler un certain
nombre d'offres de services de proximité
pour mieux révéler cette fluctuation
violences intrafamiliales
nous allons également développer toute
notre offre de formation interne de
sensibilisation auprès des publics
vulnérables et singulièrement
aujourd'hui nous étoffons ces trois là
de manière complémentaire avec le tissu
associatif qui vient en appui de nos
propres actions pour mettre à
disposition là pour le coup une juriste
qui viendra prendre le relais sur un tas
de questions que les victimes pourraient
se poser sur la constitution d'un
dossier donc de divorce ou tout autre
sujet rapprochant un peu plus longuement
avec le président de l'association
france victime 78 dans un instant juste
c'est une première dans les yvelines est
ce que ça pourrait en amener d'autres
peut-être dans d'autres brigades des
désirs line en outre que celle de houdan
le retour d'expérience dans quelques
semaines donc hi-fi haut niveau la
brigade de houdan et il est bien
effectivement notre intention de
parfaire notre offre de proximité au
sein d'autres brigades de kayes de
brigade territoriale de gendarmerie
afin d'offrir à tous finalement le même
niveau de deux permis fin merci colonel
sylvain tortelier pour cette première
réaction je le rappelle commandant du
groupement de gendarmerie des yvelines à
propos de la signature de cette
convention acquis et lieu je le disais
il ya quelques minutes à la brigade de
gendarmerie de houdan molette on
continue à en parler dans un instant
mais tout d'abord parlons de cet accueil
de jour nouvel accueil de jour qui a
ouvert à versailles qui a été inauguré
ce mardi cette maison accueillera et des
femmes victimes de violences et les
accompagnera dans leur vie de tous les
jours avec un projet qui est porté
notamment par l'association la nouvelle
étoile dans cet accueil les opérateurs
et les opérateurs cette association dans
ce projet les précisions de nicolas
landresse
il ressemble à n'importe quel domicile
un salon une salle de jeux pour enfants
une chambre et une salle de bain
pourtant cette maison est un accueil de
jour dédié aux femmes victimes de
violences une structure opéré par
l'association la nouvelle étoile
objectif mettre en sécurité les femmes
victimes vous avez en bas et une salle
esthétique qu'on a équipé
au niveau de soins de soins que ce soit
des soins demain des soins du cheveu du
maquillage l'habillage etc ou les femmes
qui sont victimes de violences pourront
venir à être accompagné par un
professionnel soit de coiffure soit
esthétique pour prendre soin d'elle pour
reprendre de la confiance et pour
travailler aussi l'estimé de soi il se
sentir femme à part entière en plus
d'une sécurité les personnes accueillies
sont aidé un accompagnement social
médical judiciaire ou encore
psychologique situe à versailles cette
maison est la propriété du bailleur
social les résidences yvelines essonne
c'est un logement qu'on propose à la
location avec du coup un tarif
particulier un combat sorti nous de
notre parc de commercialisation pour le
transformer local associatif donc avec
des tarifs qui sont complètement
différents beaucoup plus avantageux pour
justement aider l'association sur cette
partie à ce type de structure s'inscrit
dans le renforcement de la politique de
l'état pour lutter contre les violences
conjugales on prend soin de les
localiser en général dans des villes à
proximité des transports en commun dans
des endroits accessibles ce qui est le
cas ici à versailles puisque c'est un
accueil de jour qui est situé à la fois
dans une zone pavillonnaire un très
familial très chaleureuse et à proximité
de toutes les commodités et des
transports dans les yvelines 11 espaces
d'accueil de jour dédié aux femmes
victimes de violence sont actuellement
ouverts
et on continue à parler de cette
information dont je vous parlais juste
avant ce sujet à savoir l'ouverture et
d'une première permanence des deux
victimes en brigade de gendarmerie à
houdan une convention a été signée il ya
quelques minutes entre la gendarmerie
nationale est aussi l association france
victime 78 et notre invité justement est
le président de cette association c est
louis pierre coradin qui est avec nos
bons soirs pour foire alors juste avant
de parler de la signature de cette
convention d'avoir votre réaction
représentons peut-être l'association
france victime 78 qui a été créée en
1990 et qui fait partie du réseau
national france victimes quelles sont
les missions de france victime 78
donc la toiture
trente victimes soit 118 donc comme vous
le dites a été créé en 90 et ce qui est
important c'est qu'elle a été agréé par
ministère de la justice et que nous
sommes une association dont sur le
département
donc nous nous avons à la fois des
bénévoles et des salariés
et nous intervenons tant sur le plan
juridique psychologique
c'est une aide aux victimes sur
plusieurs plans
nous intervenons également avant pendant
et après les profils du nord donc les
larmes donc c'est un accompagnement sur
toutes les phases de cette procédure ce
phénomène de violences intrafamiliales
violences conjugales puisqu'on parle de
ça aujourd'hui est-ce que de votre point
de vue président d'une association où
vous avez l'impression que sur les zones
rurales il a augmenté il a progressé sur
sur ces derniers mois notamment du
peut-être au confinement aux différents
confinement fait dans la ruralité est
fait pour toi que notre optique fêter
également
d'aller vers les territoires ruraux que
nous ne faisions pas jusqu'à présent et
c'est pour cette raison que nous avons
pris cette convention avec la
gendarmerie nationale
vous demandez ça change quoi
concrètement pour vous la signature
cette convention c'est d'aller vers le
rural d'être un peu plus présents sur le
territoire rural yvelinois alors bon
notre notre association a son siège à
versailles mais notre idée c'est à la
fois la proactivité c'est à dire d'aller
en contact au contact des victimes et
deuxièmement d'aller vers c'est-à-dire
de défendre à livrer nos pères nos
permanences alors comment ça s'organise
justement une permanence comment elle va
s'organiser sept permanents je lui
disais un qui va prendre place dans la
brigade de gendarmerie de houdan molette
mais à écouter notre notre juriste
orphan a déjà
prix protection si on peut dire
aujourd'hui donc elle ne fait pas tout
allait
dans la dans la brigade la télé très
bien accueilli d'ailleurs et donc chaque
tous les quinze jours un après-midi tous
les quinze jours elle sera là pour donc
senna julie c'est à dire que pour le
moment nous n'avons des permanences
extérieures avec nike au niveau
juridique les il est possible que dans
un avenir cela dépendra de des
conditions puisque nous ne subsistant
que graf a amené la subvention donc il
est possible et c'est envisager déjà
dans une offre permanente de faire
sickology être implanté au sein d'une
gendarmerie ça va permettre aussi
d'avoir un lien plus direct avec les
forces de l'ordre
louis-pierre coradin qui ne nous entend
plus président de france victime 70
alors on va passer juste à une dernière
question je vous demandais juste si le
fait d'être présent directement dans la
la brigade de gendarmerie ça allait
permettre d'avoir un lien peut être un
peu plus direct justement avec les
forces de l'ordre
on a perdu la connexion avec lui pierre
coradin je le rappelle un président de
france victime 78 et d'ailleurs si vous
voulez prendre contact avec cette
association vous soyez victime peut-être
témoin aussi un de violences conjugales
vous pouvez contacter l'association via
le lien qui s'affiche le lien qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et à
l'occasion de la journée internationale
des droits des femmes les communes se
mobilisent aussi une semaine spéciale se
déroule notamment du côté de la ville de
trappes à verneuil-sur-seine
verneuil-sur-seine la municipalité a
fait imprimer des sacs à baguette avec
des messages de prévention une action
inspirée de celle du collectif nous tout
sur ces sachets des numéros d'urgence
pour les femmes victimes de violence
mais aussi des violons connaître cet
outil permet de mesurer le degré de
violence dans un couple à partir
d'exemples du quotidien est la mairie de
verneuil prévoit de distribuer dix mille
de ses emballages
[Musique]
l'autre grand titre de l'actualité
yvelinois c'est ce premier déplacement
de campagne pour emmanuel macron un peu
plus de 30 jours du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle le président
candidat s'est rendu à poissy il a
échangé avec près de 250 participants
sur les différentes thématiques comme le
pouvoir d'achat l'immigration ou encore
la guerre en ukraine nous étions sur
place avec patrick jacq de d'exp le
récit de mickaël millero
pour son premier déplacement en tant que
candidat emmanuel macron a choisi de se
rendre à poissy ce lundi 7 mars pour une
réunion publique le fief de son ami et
maire divers-droite qu'un lolif à
l'appel du président samedi soir aux
alentours de minuit et une heure du
matin pour venir je commencerai bien ma
campagne de terrain
chez toi et puis il ne voulait
absolument pas un meeting politique en
tant que tel c'est à dire avoir que des
militants autour de lui c'est pas ça qui
souhaitait le président il souhaitait
avoir des gens qui n'avaient pas
forcément voté pour lui en 2007 c'était
le cas je travaille pas de secret en
tant que la moitié de la salle n'a pas
forcément voté pour lui en 2017 avait
besoin d'éléments pour récolter ces
éléments les 250 personnes invitées au
centre de diffusion artistique ont pu
poser leurs questions au président
candidat au programme des thématiques
sur la guerre en ukraine l'immigration
encore le pouvoir d'achat
tout à l'heure je suis parti prendre
donc mettre de l'essence dans mon
véhicule et j'ai vu plus de 2 euros
monsieur le président est ce que vous
vous rendez compte que plus de deux
euros c'est juste énorme pour un
français moyen
j'ai en plus trois enfants à court terme
les prix le pouvoir d'achat ce que vous
avez dit est parfaitement vrai vous avez
été la porte parole mon avis de dizaines
de millions de françaises et de français
sur les prix de l'énergie
si je puis dire le président n'a pas
attendu le candidat le gouvernement a
pris déjà beaucoup de mesure et on doit
aller pour suivre la situation dans
lequel dans lequel je me trouve c'est la
situation dans lesquelles se trouvent
tout le monde et tout le monde est
impactée quelles que soient leurs
revenus
ddd famille un échange direct qui s'est
parfois déroulées dans une ambiance
détendue merci monsieur président
d'ailleurs mes collègues me regardent
ils attendent la réponse est ce que je
peux venir à côté de vous pour prendre
une photo s'il vous plaît
ce premier rendez vous en tant que
candidat était aussi l'occasion pour
emmanuel macron de mobiliser ses équipes
sur le terrain mais maintenant c'est
notre rôle à chacune et chacun des
militants des élus des responsables
associatifs des citoyens qui se retrouve
dans le discours du président est bien
de convaincre sur le terrain et on a 35
jours pour le faire emmanuel macron
reviendra dans les yvelines ce jeudi 10
mars avec une autre casquette celle du
président du sommet européen organisé à
versailles avec les 27 chefs d'état des
pays de l'union européenne
ils étaient cent élèves depuis septembre
dernier avec l'ouverture du nouveau
collège à mantes la jolie le collège
paul cézanne va connaître une nouvelle
vie le campus hébergera la rentrée 2022
un centre de formation et différents
domaines seront proposés aux jeunes
décrocheurs scolaires aux bénéficiaires
du rsa et demandeurs d'emploi est la
chambre des métiers de l'artisanat est
l'un des partenaires du projet porté par
le département des yvelines à terme le
site espère accueillir jusqu'à 400
étudiants les propos recueillis par
mélanie poker dans ce quartier la grande
orientation que porte la municipalité
depuis maintenant longtemps cette autour
de la pédagogie ça c'est appeler la
réussite éducative
ça s'appelle aujourd'hui la ville
apprenante ça s'inscrit d'ailleurs dans
une nouvelle formule gouvernementale de
cité éducative nous sommes tous
convaincus que par l'éducation mais par
la formation nous pourrons
entre
l'exclusion et le chômage de masse des
jeunes issus des quartiers politique de
la ville 25% des jeunes vient de montage
au nez par les averses avec pas
forcément simple nous avons des maîtres
d'apprentissage et nous avons des
professeurs qui peuvent venir ici aussi
donc on a regardé qu'est ce qui pouvait
se faire donc on a en a déduit qu
effectivement la boucherie porter
coiffure porter boulangerie porter dans
l'actualité également deux ans de prison
avec sursis et près de 29 mille euros
damende c'est ce qui est requis par le
tribunal judiciaire de versailles dans
la sphère des maltraitances animales à
auffargis sur le banc des accusés le
propriétaire de la ferme quatre étoiles
mise en cause par d'anciens employés et
des promeneurs l'association l214 et la
fondation brigitte bardot est
l'exploitant qui s'est vu retirer ses 93
bovins fin 2018 nie en bloc ces
accusations de maltraitance le jugement
sera rendu le 20 avril prochain
[Musique]
mais depuis le 10 janvier la poste a
ouvert un espace dédié au passage du
code de la route à saint germain en laye
la société a obtenu l'agrément de l'état
dans le cadre de la réforme du permis de
conduire et dans les yvelines six
centres sont mises à disposition des
candidats illustration à
saint-germain-en-laye avec célia gars
tsongo et patrick jacques de dixmude
pour
l'examen quart d'heure les 55
[Musique]
passer son code de la route avec la
poste c'est désormais possible la
société a obtenu l'agrément de l'état
dans le cadre de la réforme du permis de
conduire elle met à disposition
désormais certains de ses locaux comme
les bureaux de poste ou salles de
formation depuis janvier à saint germain
en laye un site postale dédié au passage
du code de la route est ouvert dans les
yvelines six établissements similaires
ont vu le jour à puis en cours bois
d'arcy ou encore rambouillet celui de
saint germain en laye a une spécificité
ici c'est vrai c'est très particulier
puisque c'est un centre qui ne fait que
cette activité là et sinon c'est vrai il
peut être aussi intégré à une plateforme
industrielle du courrier ou dans au
siège social de différentes directions
réaliser les examens du code de la route
c'est une mission qui s'inscrit
totalement dans la stratégie de la poste
de pour se diversifier innover de façon
à faciliter la vie pour tous dans ce
centre dix places sont proposées par
session l'examen se passe en deux étapes
une prise en main de la tablette est
ensuite l'épreuve cet après midi là
trois candidats étaient présents j'ai
fait le code un autre endroit une
première fois et j'ai pas vraiment aimé
c'est pas dans un endroit très
chaleureux on va dire que j'ai recherché
un autre endroit
quelle est leur meilleure et j'ai
regardé trouver la poste et ça m'a paru
bien donc je suis venu c'est mes parts
on voit qu'ils ont inscrits je me suis
pas très loin d'ici donc c'est pour ça
que je suis allé à celui ci ait choisi
la poste parce que comme ça j'ai pas
besoin d'y aller tout le temps de
peindre de me déplacer je peux le faire
de chez moi donc c'était plus pratique
les candidats ont leurs résultats sur
leur téléphone en 30 à 40 minutes c'est
aussi un nouveau métier pour les agents
de peste après avoir été pendant 18 ans
facteur depuis deux mois je
choisisse
cette voie suite des ennuis de santé mon
directeur m'a proposé ce poste et j'ai
fait une immersion pendant 10 à brienne
et puis formation formation internet et
puis ensuite sur le terrain en ile de
france 70 sites postaux propose de
passer l'examen du code de la route
et puis des nouvelles des cadets de la
gendarmerie pour refermer ce journal
tout cette saison tv 60,18 vous propose
une immersion au sein de cette formation
pour les jeunes qui souhaitent exercer
plus tard dans les métiers de la
sécurité pendant les vacances d'hiver il
effectué leur deuxième stage au camp
militaire de ben au menu notamment une
journée consacrée au devoir de mémoire
le reportage de célia tsongo et bixente
mais rien senti stemann le devoir de
mémoire un volet important de la
formation des cadets d'ile-de-france
jeudi 24 février lorenzo bentata et
mehdi aigles ont vécu avec leurs
camarades une journée spéciale dès
l'aube rendez-vous au carré des soldats
du cimetière municipal du chéné
aujourd'hui on
on est actuellement en train de nettoyer
les
les tombes des anciens soldats qui sont
morts pour la france et donc on a on a
plusieurs manières de nettoyer donc on
on utilise un produit pour retirer pour
retirer toutes les traces de noir et on
frotte avec avec une brosse et
et ensuite on est en train de
de repeindre en fait le nom des anciens
soldats et de pouvoir enfin permettre
que ça soit mieux
[Musique]
voir c'est quand même des soldats qui
sont morts pour la trappe là où je vis
mon pays donc voilà c'est important il
faut le faire même si c'est pas les
activistes ont souhaité
appliquer la loi la cohésion dire que
tout seul ils sont ils peuvent rien
faire et c'est avec le groupe qui sont
plus forts ils sentent qu'ils ont
quelque chose à faire pour la
collectivité franchement ils sont très
volontaires on va on va changer tomber
on va essayer d'attaquer d'attaqué sur
sur une nouvelle tombe ou sinon de
renforcer une équipe qui est déjà sur
une tombe essayez de on va essayer de
les aider un peu là est donc bon bah on
va chercher le matos et puis on va
attaquer
après plus d'une heure de labeur le
groupe de mehdi et lorenzo réhabilite
leur troisième tour de la matinée quand
soudain en a besoin d'hommes et ça donne
nous disait que c'était la tombe de son
grand père qui est qui est tombé pour la
france aussi en 1900 1915 c'est ça et et
elle était elle était très émue et une
aussi on est assez mieux justement
d'apprendre cette nouvelle et
va c'est quelque chose de bien et nous
ça nous ça nous encourage encore plus
parce qu'on sait qu'il ya quand même des
familles derrière
et
voilà c'est important de les restaurer
dans tous les cas mon grand père a été
tué en 1915 à arras près d'arras et donc
[Musique]
chaque année j'essaye de d'entretenir sa
tombe de brosser etc et là je vois que
tous ces jeunes ont fait un geste très
touchant en essayant de récupérer la le
mauvais état de la pierre et je suis
très très ému vraiment à 11 heures
sonnent la fin de ce travail d'intérêt
général
le temps d'une pause pour déjeuner puis
les cadets se sont rendus au mont
valérien à suresnes au programme visites
et cérémonie d'hommage enfin alors que
la nuit tôt une dernière étape
parisienne la cérémonie du ravivage de
la flamme sous l'arc de triomphe
lorenzo a été choisi pour être l'un des
porte drapeaux quant à mehdi il est
chargé comme le reste des cadets de
déposer une rose au pied de la tombe du
soldat inconnu je suis fier d'être ici
pouvoir être ici on a on a une chance et
je suis aussi fier de pouvoir porter le
drapeau
et pouvant être sur les champs-elysées
en plein paris c'est une première
expérience pour moi enfin pour nous tout
ceci je pense et c'est pas tous les
jours qu'on fait c'est un petit sentier
farewell en plus avec le monde qui nous
regardent autour à l'arc de triomphe
[Musique]
c'est important pour le faire comprendre
d'où ils viennent et voyez le en règle
générale je leur pose la question qui
est sous la tombe ils me répondent dans
ses pages à un inconnu dans qu'à ce
moment là je leur dis non je n'ai pas
l'inconnu c'est un soldat français une
cérémonie habituelle presque
quotidiennes au pied du grand édifice
qui restera pourtant singulière est
gravé dans la mémoire des jeunes cadets
au terme d'une journée chargée d'émotion
à
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité demain rendez-vous en
direct à 19h pour une édition spéciale
de la rédaction de tv 78 consacré à la
mobilisation yvelinoise face aux
conflits armés en ukraine ce soir ne
manquez pas un nouveau numéro du 7-8
culture présentée par célia 400 go belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]